there's a big focus on her love story um
with a guy who literally stalks her yeah
weird all of these amazing things that
that happened for that film are the
reason that you and I really get to sit
here today so Disney's new Snow White
Star her name is Rachel zler here she is
criticizing the original Disney movie as
predatory I mean you know the the
original cartoon came out in 1937 and
very evidently so um there is a big F
focus on her love story um with a guy
who literally stalks her weird weird so
we didn't do that this time the
cartoon's so beloved it's like a
Monumental moment in film history it was
like the first featurelength cartoon
movie to the point where it it won
honorary Oscars and all of these amazing
things that that happened for that film
are the reason that you and I really get
to sit here today because it made Disney
what it is so of course there's like
this pressure of being the the first one
having to bring to life the first one
and and obviously that's come with a lot
of pressure that I've put on myself and
also I mean much like Hunger Games
there's just a very dedicated group of
people who love Disney cartoons I'm one
of them you know I I love uh the
everything that the Disney company has
put out in the past um million years 100
years this year and I get it she's just
the irrelevant actress she's just a
footnote in his and doesn't really know
what she's talking about but then how
about instead of trying to destroy Snow
White a story that everyone uh remembers
that everyone watched when they were a
kid and nobody thought it was about
predatory behavior or or anything evil
how about you guys create new things but
Disney can't create new things because
wokeness is the end of creativity it's
why it destroys comedy it's why they
destroyed Star Wars it's why they can't
do anything with the Marvel movies
anymore and everything is just
repetitive driil because they
canot
create